[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
comm presents the second annual winter
chess classic you are looking live at
the world famous tournament hall at the
st. Louis chess club where outside
the weather is not too good inside
though the very best in this club and
some players internationally this is a
big international event are going
head-to-head come on into the studio and
stay awhile hello my name is Ben Simon
and I'm joined for the first time by
Grandmaster in residence Jessie cry
Jessie welcome to the broadcast this is
gonna be a lot of fun yeah happy to be
here we have already some great games
underway and I'm looking forward to it
yeah I know we got to talk to some of
the players beforehand and they're
excited to be here a lot of them have
crazy stories to tell and we're gonna
see some of that play out on the board
as well let's take a look at our masters
division these are the players that are
in the top of this event group a we call
it and five players we have in the top
100 seven that Federation's are
represented in this field from Ray
Robson and Geoffrey Zhang the real hard
hitters all the way down to Nero making
his return to competitive chess after
over a year away we saw him on the
Russian broadcast with a grand chest
tour this is gonna be this is one of the
strongest fields we've had yet in any
group a yeah it's a very nice field very
no weak no weak players no easy games in
this field and to me it's kind of a a
really nice showcase for American youth
against some of the most experienced
players in the world
we've got ropes and Zhang and Sevilla
and all very promising against the likes
of sassy Kieran who's been an on second
you know a big big phenom in the Indian
chess world
we've got moku Mian we got modal F one
of the greatest attacking players of all
time
all of these wonderful players so it's a
really good test to see our youth
against
the most experienced in the world indeed
and it's not not too shabby for Group B
either let's take a look it's a battle
of generations in this field old versus
young this is going to be very
interesting to watch Jesse well right
and for me you know although I'm for the
youth in Group A I'm very much for thank
you for the old guys and Group B guys
like Michalowski and Benjamin and peril
Stein you know those are guys are my age
and I want them to win and someday I
want to play in this event so I'm
looking at those guys in like imagining
what it'd be like to play in a very
tough event like this
Jesse cry wastes no time in selling
himself for a future classical invite
back here to one of these events if
you're not familiar with this format
let's take a look at it what we're
dealing with is 210 player round robins
the time control classical 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves with 30 minutes
added on for the remainder of the game
there is a 30 second increment from move
number one and an executive director of
the club and arbiter Tony rich made a
point to say you've got to take notation
for the entire game players may not
agree to a draw before Black's 30th move
and this is turn courage fighting chess
and if you've wanted to see fighting
chess you are in the right spot if we
took a look at those fields
now our tournament schedule is brutal
let's take a look at what's upcoming for
the next nine days there's no rest days
okay we are going straight through here
at us chess champs com1 p.m. everyday
and the games begin on that website you
can watch them live our show will begin
every day two and a half hours after the
start of the round you will notice that
on Tuesday November 13th everything will
begin - hours earlier that is because if
necessary we will have a playoff to
determine one overall champion in both
fields and you can join us all the way
YouTube u.s. chess champs comm Facebook
we are live on Twitch we are on leech s
org and this is an amazing worldwide
event we want you to join the
conversation with hashtag winter chess
classic
and big news Jesse this is risky but our
YouTube chat we will be answering your
questions live so keep it civil and if
you aren't civil banhammer yeah you know
how it is
that's how we do things here all right
let's take a look at our round one
pairings for our masters division these
games are in progress
Alexander Shimano versus Krishna and SAS
Akira you know he goes by sassy sassy
Rhea Robson versus u.s. [ __ ] sada Perez
Sam Sevilla versus darl spirits
Alexandre multi 11 versus Evgeny Morales
Shenko you can call him Nero but our key
matchup of Group A today
Jeffrey Zhang versus hunt milk Koo Yin
and this is a game that really piqued
your interest Jessie right and I want to
say first off Mel cumin is a really nice
guy he doesn't look nearly as mean as
criminal as he does in that phone just
had a bad day Jeffrey's happy though
Jeffrey's happy and he's happy in our
current position if we take a look he's
happy on two regards he's up the
exchange for let's call it dubious
compensation plus he's got an incredible
time advantage mokume ian only has three
minutes left to make 20 moves and where
they get 30 seconds to move in addition
correct but still that's not that much
and right it's kind of a but maybe we'll
take a look at how we got here but if we
just start from here let's say that
White's technical challenge now is to
open the position and to hopefully trade
off a rook on CA the rooks the extra
requite has the exchange wants freedom
and power along the D file so exchanges
are kind of the order of the day
black is probably technically lost
however the Armenians is not going to go
down with a fight he has with this pawn
on f6 he's tried to constrict some of
the white pieces and let's go back to
see how we got here because it was
really interesting also to see how the
time struggle
so let's put it here and in this
position that's kind of theoretical no
cumin started to think oh he started to
think really hard and it was surprising
because you know he was the one who
played this move a five which struck me
as like the kind of move you'd prepare
for if you were gonna do it right so in
any case he was thinking on his own here
I'm Bishop c5 and again here after 93
and came up with what I thought was a
very nice trick I I don't think this was
prepared and the idea was this 97 94 now
on the surface of things I want to say
as a Catalan player this looked terrible
for black because the bishop on c8 is
terrible and this square is nicely
blockaded by our two nights here the
bishop is looking to get out and in
addition to that White has a development
advantage so here let's look at what
black did first he Castle and then he
played this beautiful move b6 a very
hard move to see because the move Knight
f e5 looks like it's just crushing right
away
now another GM in residence has been
here quite a bit as Josh for Dell and
you know he when we analyzed together he
never never never will give up so we
made the gentleman's agreement that if I
get a knight on c6 he has to resign and
that's what it looks like here it's
looking like the least by the
gentlemen's agreement or you know knight
c6 is going to happen and therefore
white has to resign but the trick was
very nice and it's this 95 and first of
all if you take here after Knight c4
you're just in trouble because the
bishop is hanging so that's the first
new ones
the second more interesting one is 95 it
looks like White's winning but I think
moco means trick was Queen c7 very
beautiful move
threatening the knight but more
importantly threatening the Queen with a
discovered attack on c2 so white saw
this white saw this and a very inventive
for black to play this win and the thing
about it too is if he didn't find
something like that then he is in
trouble anyway because the bishop on C
it won't get out so he has to take a
spider that is very inventive play and
I'm gonna call 91 amateur move from our
youngster because he first of all he
doesn't fall into it and instead he's
just going to be looking now to
patiently solve his coordination with 93
and the knight will look at the Bishop
on c5 and here's to me I'm gonna call
this the moment of the day for me was
right here where moku Mian may be
inspired by you know his recent
inventiveness over the board really
makes a interesting attempt here with
Bishop basic sacrificing the exchange
and the thing about this is he really
didn't have to do it he could have
played a move like Knight d5 and as far
as I can tell I don't know it's about
roughly equal nothing that's special so
Bishop a6 is really gonna go for it and
in the next couple moves it seemed like
Geoffrey not only played precisely but
then did not fall into time pressure
in fact it's moku Mian who was in
big-time pressure already right here he
sniped b3 rook c8 and just commonly he
plays Queen d1 and this kind of position
was the conception I think for Mel qu
Mia when he played Bishop a6 sacrificing
the exchange it's very abstract and
unclear if he has enough it'd be hard to
like judge it in advance
and there's more than one move that he
has here in the game he played Queen d5
but I would say this was his critical
moment you know maybe Queenie for if we
talked to him after the game he might
want out of Queenie four or maybe ninety
four but he chose Queen d5 and it looks
for a second like we're gonna be able to
maybe play Bishop b7 and create some
grief on the light squares but
unfortunately really the the knight is
just on e one is just going to return to
f3 to block all that off so somewhere
around here Mel kuhnian realized it's
not going like I wanted it to go anymore
94 Knight f3 and now I think here's
where he switches gears into trying to
play defensive chess
Bishop takes pawn takes Queen c6 and now
he's just gonna try to hold the position
which once he gave up the unopposed
light square Bishop which is kind of
like the whole dream of the position
it's clear he is not doing anything
specially more now he's just going to be
playing defense and here's our so return
to our current position and that's where
we are and like I said there are
technical difficulties for Geoffrey but
it looks very good it looks very good
for him yeah it looks like we may have
maybe at least a couple more moves
played e5 is played in this position I'm
told oh yeah it should be three not
updating that now it now it has oh okay
so let's say this let's go back for a
second so f6 let's yeah very simple move
now played Queen d3 it's why we're gonna
touch tonight and we're also going to be
thinking about rook F t1 and that brings
me actually another important thing
about this position normally when
someone sacrifices something against you
you're the one who has the more
difficult position to play but in fact
here it's much simpler for white he
knows what to do he just we're gonna put
the rooks in the middle so Queen d3
night f8 not a happy move
Bishop III and now II five so let me try
to explain what I think black is
dreaming of the pawns on f6 and E 5 are
dominating the knight on f3 so at least
we have that and also he's trying to say
it's not that bad of a deal if white
goes into the endgame with Queen d5 it's
obviously very pleasant though for white
there's more than one move here I'm sure
probably rook F D 1 is playable Queen d5
is playable black is going to come and
play 96 though in fact I believe if
Queen d5 that 96 is the intention and
the only reason to believe that maybe
white doesn't win instantly is because
the knight on f3 is not that happy right
because it's blocked in by those pawns
on f6 and E 5 now you have a puzzled
look on your face so well so the the f3
Knight yeah what would you suggest here
to to go back is it is this is my
position now let me go back to the live
position here this is where white really
has this is what we call a pleasant
choice or a luxury choice right because
you have more than one good move here
right you can do rook FD one Queen d5
maybe even Knight d2 to immediately ask
the knight a question oh I called look
at that 92 that's what he did and let's
call I want to call that another mature
move because there's other things that
white could have done but something I
admire about that move is he realizes
that his knight on f3 was the only true
problem in the position and so he goes
to instantly fix it right so very nice
and now we get an exchange on e3 and
Knight c5
so incredibly pleasant position now for
black for white but notice it's still
not over the night's going to come to e6
and try to get some kind of counter play
and and let's say this the the key
question is are the white rooks going to
be able to penetrate on the D file and
are we going to be able to block to get
black out of this blockading position
that he has on c5 so I'm gonna call this
a technically one position but there's
still some drama left yeah well this is
something we're definitely gonna keep
our eyes on right but in the meantime
let's take a look at Group B and there's
some okay there's multiple stories going
on right here first of all here are the
games going on we have Lucas van forest
versus Arum Jaco be on Robbie Kepesh
melee versus Joel Benjamin zabun and
ricean versus Eugene peril Stein we have
a game that's ended and if you look on
us chest champs calm there was some
confusion because it looked like it
never began it was a forfeit
JJ Alomar on D playing for Turkey has
earned himself a point and he's got the
day off easy work right there the truth
is T mark garea is not here team or
garam is still scheduled to play in this
tournament however he missed his flight
yesterday I heard that he was playing in
another tournament when the flight was
supposed to take off not sure how that's
organized but regardless he's supposed
to be here in st. Louis later this
evening so he will play the remaining
eight rounds at a potential one-point
deficit and he will still be eligible
for all prizes this is the first time
something like this has happened in one
of these seasonal classic events so this
is new but hopefully we will see Timur
tomorrow it's fully expected that we
will and this is the only forfeit of
this event so now we all know about the
free spirit known as team Margaret of
the the cover boy of chess Life magazine
this month but our key matchup now in
group V is green
versus Israel Nicholas theodoro versus
Victor Michalowski a former group the
champion here at the classic let's take
a look at the game Jesse
yeah it's evolving recently well for big
Mick there's some well maybe not
there's okay big Mick is a known expert
in the green field and its Nick big Mick
that's weak for big make a left ski big
ook wrong guy ok and he's a known expert
in the green felt and so his opponent
did well to kind of do some interesting
offbeat line to get him maybe a little
bit tricked and we have in front of us
kind of a critical question for big Mick
let's just say he's actually in a little
bit of trouble let's look if King takes
on e8 x 4 and you got a wonder if big
Mick is going to live through that for
example on g4 well it's just bad it's
just a bad situation you're gonna have
to do I don't know something like f6
that's why big Mick is thinking about
this King takes a 8 move so maybe our
young Greek player is very much taking
control of the old guys and again I am
rooting for the old guys and this would
be terrible for me I've played big Mick
many times he is very hard to beat but
here we are and move 25 and he's
definitely in trouble maybe let's go
back a little bit and look how he got
here yeah let's let's let's start around
here white got this position and it
looks on the surface as if it shouldn't
be so threatening
however after night before takes takes
Knight c5 white has these two beautiful
knights on e5
see five and it's not entirely clear
what big mix should do in particular
what do you do about the pawn on B seven
now big make is always tricky whenever
he played me he was tricky so he starts
off with Bishop d2 and goes back and
asked do you want to draw the young
Greeks says no I'll play over here now
in some ways it feels like a concession
because now the rook isn't on the a file
and now big make plays rook c7 and maybe
I sure actually he missed night before
that was the shot the big Mick missed
why why is that the rook so the rook on
c8 wants to defend the pawn on b7 that's
why he plays rook c7 but he doesn't
realize that on 94 BAM he's just hanging
yeah you're hanging the knight on f6
right so if rook c1 Knight f6 and we're
in trouble yeah let me go through that
line actually rook c1 Knight f6 King g7
rook c1 King f6 and both g4g for looks
like wins on the spot but rook c7 also
looks completely badly so very
unpleasant now let me just say over the
edges a dr. big Mick tonight as an older
guy one thing I know is you start
suffering senior moments and I think
this is a senior moment it's unfortunate
to say but I think that's all guys we we
just start start missing things at a
certain level and almost anything would
be would have been better than rook c7
c7 a blunder 94 then big McBride 98 but
after this it's looking real bad he does
take on ei like we snow no in fact that
was just my variations excuse me this is
our position here and big Mick is
thinking about taking this night
unfortunately the night is threatening
just to come back
so that night needs to be dealt with
looking real bad for big Mick now big
Mick turns 46 this year yeah how old are
you 46 so that's so that's old by chess
standards no yeah ancient ancient in
fact you know in the group a I don't
think there's any what's the oldest
person 33 or something saucy at like 30
something you know it's it's pretty it's
pretty young yeah 30 no no no no mero
mero mero is the oldest in group a he
turns 40 this year right yeah okay I
want to say let's actually let's do this
before we go back to group a well
there's actually a I guess that's maybe
what you saw on DRA seein versus peril
Stein Rob we may not look at it for too
long and I'll say this about my friend
peril Stein he held quite easily in this
game he played an opening that I thought
he was gonna get in trouble for let's
just put that up on the board this is
this famous accelerated dragon that
peril Stein has been playing at least 15
years
it was absolutely it had to be no
surprise to Andre Ozzy and what is
happening in this that this was going to
happen but peril Stein is very good in
these positions and this is actually
like an advertisement for knowing you're
opening really well like like not being
afraid of any of the prep and just
knowing it really well and yeah he just
confidently plays this out to a drawn
situation right there boom f4 and now
everything comes off and it's basically
already now it's a draw so very nice
plate from peril Stein to just solidly
enter this as an old man I'm sure people
are gonna be gunning for him this is it
he's like lower rated and he's the old
guy they're gonna try to kill him so
this was a nice draw and we could yeah
that was clear that was going to be a
draw quite some time ago
now okay just because we're on the
subject of old man let's check in on my
friend drill Benjamin this game has been
going back and forth
okay we're staying with Group B we're a
group b yeah we're gonna go to group a
in just a second but I will say this
game has been going back and forth it's
been looking like it's been Pleasant for
white for some time and I think after
night b7 we can say that white
definitely has what could be called the
nagging yank right he's got some
pressure on black it's not so easy to
get out but you know Benjamin is famous
for holding on to slightly difficult
positions so we'll be looking at this
one so so far not looking so great for
the old guys but we're not gonna give up
yet
all right Joe Benjamin is making his
return to the club after quite a while
away the last event he played here was
the 2013 US Championship it was a 24
player Swiss it was actually the last
Swiss national championship we had here
at the club right so it's good to have
him back good to see him as one of the
as you say old guys in the field if you
will
yeah Group B yeah there is a game van
forest versus Hawk Obion oh I think he
should glance at sure where we danced
back to Group A Lucas man forest if you
haven't seen him before
are you familiar with Robin van Kampen
yes uh-huh they look nearly identical
well I'm a Dutch guy - by at least
genetics and I don't look that good
these guys look really good yeah you
know I don't look that good yeah yeah
is there like models well you know let's
not put them over too hard here and I'm
sure the Robin van Kampen is somewhere
listening so it's been a while since
white sacrificed some stuff and it looks
like black gave it back and we have a
full-on mess here
why don't we go back just a touch to see
where some of this madness happened I
think right around here
so in this position white his rook is
hanging on a - and he says you know what
you can have my rook and black says okay
I'll take it then Queen c1 Queen B one
giving it back all right
so very forcing variation then we get
this endgame where I think we should say
that it should be winning for white so a
very nice yeah
very beautiful play from the young
Dutchman who is still I believe in I am
right or it maybe I'm no maybe I'm wrong
about that
so in this position I think he's gonna
win the poor King is just getting
crushed over there and you know what's
gonna happen
rook g3 is gonna come g4 is gonna come
should be lost what was was that Queen
exchange a few moves ago was that the
mistake from Hawk Obion well I don't
know let's go maybe a little bit earlier
in fact
it's funny with this Bishop III thing
because you know this is the same
variation that Benjamin's opponent he's
also playing against this is an
old-school ruie so kept I'm gonna
pronounce the name wrong keval ish Billy
played this against Benjamin this Bishop
III thing as well and we got this
position and it seems like normally
black is supposed to be okay d5 is
arguably the controversial move however
and that would have been blacks
intention from the start so Bishop g5
aggressively puts the knight to the
question to the question they were
asking the part of d5 too so what has to
happen you're already in trouble because
on de 494 Queen d5 something like that
has to happen to get yourself out of the
pin on f6 and it's here where I can you
know it's not that difficult to spot but
it's beautiful with Bishop f6 and the
problem is is after you take my rook
after Queen c1 I have a very simple
threat of coming to g5 and really the
only way out is to play Queen B 1 so
that's how we got this and so you have
very nice you know when you play the
Ruby you kind of have to wait for your
chances and then 4 is definitely seized
it here with Bishop g5 yeah so the
mistake is somewhere over here about the
decisions that black takes in this
position because this position should be
fundamentally ok for black
yeah so nice game there are you familiar
with either of these particular players
man forest or hawk opium not so much no
you know two new faces for me I know
there's a lot of players returning in
this event probably more so than usual
in this classic so it's nice to have
these little reunions every now and then
but also nice to meet some of the new
players yeah yeah so a reminder if you
want to look at games other than what
we're watching check out us chess champs
calm and you can see all the games live
as they're happening and then we have a
little video insert up in the corner as
well we do have someone said in the chat
that the stream is just not the same
without a seasonal gimmick like the
pumpkins we had with Eric Rosen
now I'm sure give us a moment here we
might be able to do something how about
that how was that they wanted it you got
it there's more coming so alright can we
play the video of a tough team were
jumping out of the airplane my gimmick I
want to play that video let's wait until
he gets here that's what really gets
here just in case
let me just say my theory about Timur is
that he was on the airplane and he just
you know in Russia things work a little
differently talk to the stewardesses oh
by the way it just in case you don't
know
so Timur garea the cover boy chess Life
magazine this month it was jumping out
of an airplane on the photo shoot and he
has a wooden chess board I I imagine
that the pieces are glued onto the board
they don't move and he's jumping out of
a plane it's a great video amazing video
we're gonna show this video a lot and we
do have a video if you want to watch it
right now the US Chess Federation u.s.
chess youtube has it on there on there
channel allso u.s. chess org it's
amazing stuff I'm hesitant to put the
guy over if he's not here yet well I was
gonna hear later tonight I was gonna say
I think what happened is he talked to
the stewardesses he got on the plane and
he was ready to come here but he's like
I've had already the first adrenaline
and I wanted again so somewhere over the
Atlantic mmm he just got out of the
plane of jump man
he landed on dry land best I could tell
hopefully so we had so that was the the
first game that ended in Group B in the
first decision what other games have
caught your eye
perhaps in group ages let's take a look
at some of the young uns and let's start
with Ray ropes and and let's actually go
through this game from the start and you
call him Robson where I thought it was
Robson I don't know actually with the
tip maybe we'll have to double check on
them yeah when he was up I'll just say I
first heard Ray's name probably around
2007 and maybe then people were calling
him Rossini he was tiny and he was like
we all thought he was the next coming
and he kind of has been and I love the
way he played this opening here it felt
like he caught casada off guard and got
this very nice III move in where the e3
pawn is gonna blunt the knight on d4 and
the Bishop on c5 and more importantly
after castles were going to shut it down
with d4 so I felt after h3 preventing
Bishop g4 that this was a very
successful opening because blacks pieces
are dominated now in this position I
think black made a move I'm eager to
talk to him and ropes in about that
seems very controversial to me when I
was a kid they said do not take the pawn
on d4 because that's your friend that
pawn on e5 he's working for you he's
part of your center and of course you're
also freeing Robeson's bishop on c1 when
you take so I think anything's better
than taking 94 h6 queen somewhere don't
take any d4 Robeson got this position h6
Knight c3 a 6 a 3 I love this move -
we're just gonna slowly expand on the
Queen side and the idea is to take all
the squares away
from the black pieces 97 rookie won c-6
and here's the moment that I'd like to
ask the players about when they come in
I feel like white is better here and
that he can do a variety of different
moves but the movie he played I really
don't like and this is going to lead to
what I think is going to be the unclear
struggle that we're gonna find before us
right the bishop on b6 currently not
that active blunted by the d4 pawn kind
of like the the the core of whites
advantage and for reasons that are
inexplicable to me ropes and play d5
problem solve for black problems over
black and then now I'd be happy to play
this position is black our pieces all
have reasonable squares and yeah it's
just gonna turn into a mess the pawn on
f2 not so happy the King therefore not
so happy and so various things happen
black looks fine it's a messy situation
yeah we're coming close to where we are
I'd rather be black all of a sudden and
it makes sense so you know white gave us
what we wanted h5 rook a3 root K 3 is
the kind of move you make when things
aren't going so well Bishop f5 and here
we are by no means over or anything like
that but simply a successful launch into
the game for casada especially after
that opening where I felt like he should
have been getting hurt all right now
another strange game for from our young
players that I don't know if so strange
but let's just check it out
Sam Sevilla is a longtime competitor
here at the Chess Club that's right we
saw him basically grow up around the
time he was getting his Grandmaster
title he started playing here mmm I
believe it was I think it was the 2013
u.s. champs was the first time he played
in
that particular event here yeah so he
feels like somewhat of a hometown
favorite even though he's not daro
spirits though is a home towner he came
here to go to slough he's on the st.
Louis University team so yeah definitely
too promising up and comers in the world
of chefs yeah I first met Sam I guess
2010 he was just a little kid mm-hmm and
you know he was one of these genius kids
and like everybody else you know it's
the the that are about everybody but of
the kids who have made 2600 at an early
age then the big question is is can they
go further can they go beyond that and
obviously all three of them Savion
Robson and John are gonna be looking for
big tournaments this here today and big
wins today and so the first thing is
interesting to me is this move there's
been a number of attempts now by white
to fight the night or and basically
they're all weird I think white stripe
they weird things like h3 here all kinds
of strange moves that make absolutely no
sense to me what it shows is that the
white players are basically frustrated
with this Nye Dorf and so it's been
proving itself and Knight b3 is
obviously kind of funny because in so
many variations of the Sicilian black is
trying to make that Knight move away
from the center
but what Savion has in mind is to play
like a reversed English and so he's
losing this tempo now and black says
okay let's reverse the English it's
getting reversed English and 7 gets this
position which I have had as black with
reverse colors obviously I had one tempo
less and now plays this mildly
controversial move Knight
97 Queen c1e 6 back B 5 and here I feel
like black is fine no big problems and
like what often happens when you play
the play against the Sicilian is you
have to be careful that your Knights
don't end up getting dominated so this
guy doesn't have a lot of squares and
this one the knight on c3 doesn't have
squares to go to either and another
thing about the Sicilian that definitely
applies here is that the c2 pawn is not
fighting for the center at the moment
and later might become a victim with the
rook on ca right so let's get a couple
more moves a3 that's a sad move to make
rugby one visit v7 Knights e4 black
seems very fine here and is really
pushing for it now with night with E 5
beautiful so to me it looks like black
has had a very successful open to this
game but there's still a lot of
questions remaining especially right
here about how this is going to move
forward and whether what black really
has something or maybe it's not so
special obviously the threat of d4 needs
to be dealt with right so yeah the kids
it's not so easy let's let's do an
update on Geoffrey's game see where he
is yeah sure our key matchup in Group A
this was I mean it was a crate pic we
call it the key magic before we knew but
this is this is still within Geoffrey's
favor Jesse let's take a look at what
happened since we left obviously a bunch
of moves been played we're getting into
time pressure
welcome home has a minute under a minute
left and White's just playing all the
standard stuff he's trying to trade his
night actually that's a nice move with
night b7 at least on a practical level
because he's saying if you can't I'm
gonna try to play against the night so
remember when the night was on a three
we're saying the night is bad here black
is trying to say okay I'm not completely
lost because your night is bad that's
why I'm not gonna let you trade it off
and I'm not gonna let you trade anything
but the nights now the night is the
least looking at the d4 square again
this looks lost but it's mokume ian is
putting up some pressure f4 is an
interesting move because it's saying I'm
gonna give you a pawn but what I want in
return for that pawn is to open the
position for both my knights and my
rooks actually I like this move a lot EF
494 and so now you either have to trade
something or let my knight which we're
trying to make bad right it was like the
one thing the black had was a bad night
and seve on his sac to put pause United
7 it's on us act upon just to get the
knight free so a very good practical
move King f7 rook b1 now it's getting
critical with the b6 weakness takes
takes Knight g5 takes
this is completely lost
yeah you can't it's over you can't move
the rook the knight which was the worst
piece is now a fantastic piece the pawn
on c4 is passed we've regained the pawn
that we had lost so in a position like
this one thing we sometimes say is that
White has the pawn and the compensation
right yeah very nice play from Jean and
so and right now actually as I'm looking
at a different shot of the board the
rooks have been exchanged oh yeah yeah
yeah that's let's refresh let's see how
that happened
so Knight b6 a very simple play yeah and
like actually I want to say this is a
very instructive moment for anybody
watching when you're playing against
someone who sacrificed exchange it's a
really good idea to trade your
opponent's rooks and the reason is is
that for a long time White's rooks have
been doing that often times the same
thing kind of doing the same job whereas
the rook and Knight blacks work at night
they do different things so by getting
rid of his rook it really is gonna make
the Knights look helpless and they're
definitely help us here with ninety
eight in here well there's nothing doing
really we're gonna march the C pawn and
honestly I think even without the C pawn
this is probably this is a winning
position yeah it's often really hard to
predict when a player is gonna throw in
the towel because it's so much on that
player's temperament right and I don't
know much about Malcolm Ian hardly
anything so how long do you think that
he'll play on before he gives it a rest
against Geoffrey he'll definitely play
on to at least after move forty cuz that
he's gonna get and he's going to get
some more time I move forty and then he
can at least think about it it looks
like they're on move forty right about
now yeah so
well it's race Jeffries oh we have a
result on another board here as van
forest has vanquished his opponent
Hakuba Marin in Group B that's our first
decision we've seen this that well one
our zero one across the board here today
so maybe we can get Ferran forest in
here to talk about his game with Jaco
bien
yeah that was a nice game let's just
look where we stopped last time oh my
god how did this even happen so in this
position the knight is threatening to go
to e7 situation critical 97 now the king
is forced back Bishop f6 this is a nice
move because if you play rook g3
immediately black gives some you give
black some semblance of a hope with f6
so we're just gonna really lock down the
mating pattern here with Bishop f6 first
and then play rook g3 this is like one
of those pol garm 8 positions honestly
we're kidding
we're controlling all the squares around
the black King and so this is lost but
let's see how he finished it off rook e8
rook g3 h5 to get some lift check to the
misérable King check to the misérable
King and it's really time to resign here
f4 f4 is a really beautiful brutal and
beautiful move he's just gonna put the
pawn on f5 and then say mate oh yeah not
much to do about that you know not much
to do so yeah a very nice game and I
think you know I they're gonna be
looking at the game now and at some
point black made a critical
miscalculation let's say somewhere
around here with taking on d4 as you
know from our analysis of the ropes and
game I do not like it I like yourself is
he 5 5 he does it he better get
something for it and in the game he must
have been saying to himself oh if I get
the bishop on a2 then my game will be
beautiful but for us said you know what
that's a beautiful night on c3 then I
can't go to c3 until you take that's a
beautiful night and in fact that's the
night one of the nights is gonna end up
hurting you later right Bishop g5 boom
there it comes
so yeah something about that black
didn't see coming very well one of the
games we haven't yet looked at in a half
a multi-level Nero Russia versus Ukraine
right here but both the Russian speakers
I think we should take a look at what's
going on I spent a lot of time in the
playing hall looking at the beginnings
of this game
well this look at the King look at why
it's king right there what's it doing
it's a beautiful King it controls way
more squares than the black King and I
really like the way moto left played
this now I just say modal F is known as
being one of the greatest attacking
players that's ever been okay and I
believe that also one of the greatest
technicians but in this game he headed
straight for the endgame after this in
the petrov here i am not too familiar
with this kind of thing though i've seen
similar variations and it seems as if
there's not that much going on here but
the nice thing is that white can
continue to play in creative ways as he
does in this game and i love let's start
off with this move f3 it's going to be
very nice the king is going to come to
f2 we're threatening things like g4 just
just sorry erupted i think we do have
Lucas man forest ready for a great so
keep on looking at this game and I'll
return shortly okay great yeah and so f3
not only prepares g4 but as we see in
the end position not the end but what
the current position the White King is
going to be better than the black King
and so it's not probably still in an
equal position but it's an interesting
way of playing a slow endgame and the
nice thing is here the knight is going
to come to g3 to try to embarrass the
bishop on f5
and here I thought maybe Knight b6 but
Miro plays knight of fate Bishop d7 he
should still be okay King F 296 and now
93 I like the move a lot avoiding the
exchange and intending to plant the
knight on e5 so that's what happens and
we have mr. Van Voorhis with us we're
gonna hook him up and maybe ask him a
question or two about the game I'll pull
it up so Lucas happy to have you here
yeah let's take a look and maybe walk me
through some of the what you thought
were the key moments of this yeah okay
so thinking the opening was normal
yeah this b5 move it was played by Chuck
Oh Franco I think it's from game but I
didn't really remember anything but just
for our fans I was I thought I was a
little surprised by what would you say
is the idea just to play b4 and get some
play on the beef yeah it's it's just
before B takes c3 and then who knows
that yeah I actually I mean I only knew
it was a move but I didn't know like I
also did not know what the idea was
exactly right it's very concrete so well
let me ask you this it felt to me like
blacks big decision came here yeah what
to do or actually let's call it right
there right after Bishop III
well actually I was not sure about Ruby
8 because I what happens if he thinks on
c3 in place
rook e8 right right he decides to go on
an adventure on the queenside it seems
like more traditional would be you know
at some point play edie and d5 sure or
rook e8 or something like that yeah
that's what but okay it cannot be really
a bad move for Paige okay but I felt I I
had some control over the center after
Bishop e3 and maybe you talked to Iran
after the game did did he miss something
here with it what with with what now
Cain
yeah I think he he miss it if it awaited
the ending actually so we saw maybe you
both all saw everything books really
yeah I'm surprised but he just told me I
I thought he just blown up some air buds
no okay so you guys this is really an
interesting moment because when I looked
at the game I came to this moment I said
it's blackness something around yeah
yeah but in fact we're gonna walk
through this and apparently he did see
quite far so let's walk through it a
little bit takes it takes takes takes
night before yeah this all looks forced
to me so just let's just say for the
fans on a positional level black is
gonna say I'm gaining this beautiful
Bishop on a - yeah and that's somehow it
was a big deal however before your night
could not go to c3 now it gets to go to
aisle three that's kind of a big deal so
IFT Center maybe he's like bone
structure advantage and and development
yeah and the bishop on a seven not so
great yeah it was out of the game like
for the rest of the game and here after
rook takes maybe he should play Bishop
e6 but I would guess that white is a bit
better but you wouldn't go for this
unless you had some idea already yeah
yeah yeah no I didn't calculate that
more so I only calculated T five because
right five looks really that's the only
thing if that works like it's totally
fine right so you're saying he saw
Bishop g5 yeah Wow
well he told me okay I I didn't assume
that he missed Bishop d5 maybe he wanted
to take they can maybe play Bishop b7
did is just worse yeah I would play
Knight takes f6 G takes and Bishop h6
and okay he will have the bishop era but
this Bishop on a7 is still out of play
and okay his kings King safety is really
ok well let's show this variation Queen
d5 yeah nice takes takes it looks
terrible
yeah we'd a - yeah are here I also had
some other interesting option group e5
haha and it's and after eight six
because I threatened the chief argument
I was thinking about rook h5
Group B 1 uh-huh Luke takes 8 6
yeah yeah yeah and then you take King
takes a king it's Uruk H 1 and then I
cannot take because then Queen B 1 right
but I play King t3 and and I win
but the problem is yes he's our queen
and I broke up
but the problem for me is that he
doesn't have to play root B 1 you can go
root B 6 because I'm just an entire rope
down and after rook takes H 6 you will
take on f6 and then you should be better
it would be surprising effect worked out
for you but I was really hoping it would
like how amazing would that be yeah we
win the game in this fashion but after
Queen shawarma amazing that he saw this
Queen see ya Queen B 1 ok it's for so
just let's just say White was
threatening Queen g5 and now Queen g6 is
the defense but yeah of course you're
you're not fully protected on beat 1 so
Lucas takes but I was also surprised
that he went for this light and
intentionally and you know we were
talking the broadcast I said White has
the pawn and the compensation yeah like
to me you know it looks like well yeah
it looks like I'm just winning here so
he saw this and whoa okay so what he did
what did he miss so maybe so maybe he
just thought that okay I'm slightly
worse but I have Bishop error but and he
did not really see that his King King
King safety is really a big deal yeah so
he maybe thought like Bishop d6 which
was played rook e1 and then there are
some important technical new arms that
Bishop f5 doesn't work after rupee one
so it's the point that if he doesn't
play Bishop e6 if he says plays rook e8
now yeah maybe that's probably better
and it will give the best but maybe he
was worried about a 5 in Derek c1 or
something like that yeah rook C Wang I
have many plans yeah a lot of plans but
this Bishop is just will be caged in
it's so there's so many terrible things
that you can hurt him with like I was
thinking actually just with rook e8
there
excuse me with rook e8 like on rook c1
Bishop d6 you could even maybe do a 5
now um well here I can take right
because I can go to f/8 but it's still
tricky but me like take oh no I mean of
course I don't know exactly so these
weeks this looks I wouldn't want this
yeah it's really scary yeah but maybe it
just just works out for like maybe if I
I mean I don't think I could see that
far ahead anyway but if I did I would
say no and there's just too many things
to be scared about
I agree yeah so alright you took and
let's say I saw what he missed here it's
quite important that's Bishop f5 uh-huh
if he gets dead in he will maybe have
some drunk chances all right but the
problem is that I can play a 55 right
let's take a look at that
it's a Bishop f5 and the very simple a5
and he takes up a rookie five with the
rebel attack boy yeah though okay let
let's just let me just play devil's
advocate let's pretend a5 wasn't there
Yeah right okay and you do something
like either g4 rookie five it still I
don't know it still doesn't yeah okay so
it's something to hope for and actually
it's his this ending says only try after
Queen d5 like right this is the only
thing you could play and of it a5 I was
just like okay how can I make the guy
sure absolutely you've got the pawn and
the compensation you got everything
going for you here yeah I really liked
this this maneuver I did to 96 very nice
yeah yeah just
it looks game over here mm-hmm yeah I
like that a lot
it's about five yeah and here he okay
basically seven is of course we're
losing immediately you should try Bishop
c4 okay because software rubgy three he
can go King of five and then it's not so
clear
oh and if 97 King 873 then he can maybe
try f6 Yeah right okay yeah so it's it's
not easy actually yeah so route III King
Fi
yeah sure what's going on here exception
huh so you must have just felt like in
principle that shouldn't work out for
him yeah okay you should definitely be
lost here clear super clear-cut way of
their Bishop e4 at least he has some
some small hope so
okay let's let me just play devil's
advocate for six Oh 97 King h7 and and I
don't know rook f6 mmm-hmm
yeah those black has a move it's hard
right and if nothing else I can play
Knight f5 I can I can do a bunch of
things I feel right yeah the threats
right now is probably f3 or f3 or thing
it may be king h2 just okay so Bishop d7
and now you got a very nice mating net
here right and it's just over and we're
gonna show one nice move here black
could resign here but I like this f4 cuz
now you're gonna play f5 and yeah so we
got the yes to play Bishop c2 probably
here and then g4z 4 and I will just
continue with f5 and then this King
doesn't have a lot of squares no that's
correct
well very nice game yeah yeah quite
correct from the white side at least you
know well thank you very much and good
luck in the rest of tournament Thanks
alright
all right we're gonna go for a
commercial break and we'll be right back
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals for the
Blues what about after the game heading
back to the hotel would be a major error
sted pulled you through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway or stir bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill
so whether you love the Cardinals the
Blues or the Blues come play with us and
you guys know I can't play this right
st. Lou is always exploring alright we
are joined here with Jeffrey Zhong who
was one a very nice round one game
against rant mill Quyen one of the top
players in the world a member of the
Armenian team and so Jeffrey let's take
a look let me ask a question so I was
following this game and you know we get
this Catalan and I don't know too much
about this variation but what's
interesting to me was that right around
here Mike who mean started thinking yeah
right he started thinking a long time it
surprised me because you haven't done
anything that abnormal right well no he
was thinking after night a3 like right
93 yeah because yeah actually he's he's
the only player who has ever tried the
system uh-huh and yeah no one has ever
played this before actually I had a game
against Malcolm young in blitz and I and
I played something else
so yeah this caught him off guard a bit
well you know it's it's odd I mean let's
just say it's a little weird what he's
done right because he's played a5 and c5
the d5 square is loose and your
development is amazing the Bishop on c5
maybe doesn't want to be there right and
I I was really kind of inspired with
what he did because first of all it
wasn't good that he thought so long
right here's where he really take but he
came up with I thought an interesting
way to deal with what looks like on the
surface to most Catalan players is going
to look like a very
in position coming up real quick here
right so we had 97 takes castles castles
b6 and I was looking at it was like well
I want to play 95 play 95 and you may
you tell me it looked like there was the
trick was that if you play here he was
gonna do this dirty thing to you
this is yeah I actually got this
position a couple of days ago Wow
yeah you had this exact position i I
mean I checked a lot of night moves but
uh-huh
actually I was thinking you because yeah
I realized that after 91 he can second
exchange it I I mean I checked that but
I couldn't actually remember what to do
so I to make sure that this is the
correct position and so you that's right
because you were moving very quickly and
you had so you had 91 as part of your
prep yeah yeah Wow well that AME is just
a huge advantage wasn't it yeah like you
were had almost all your time and he was
thinking so much it was weird to me
because yeah he he's the one who played
this offbeat line so it was strange that
he was thinking so much well then I gave
you too much credit earlier about 91
because I thought that was a very mature
move are you just getting all your
pieces on the right squares right and 93
you're just better here right I I
analyzed I think is both 95 rookie 7
you're also playing right I and to me
this was the most interesting moment of
the entire day today where he decided to
play Bishop base 6 but I think I mean if
I were black I would probably do the
same really it looks very promising at
first I feel interesting ok um whereas
Knight d5 I thought it was like
completely wool or something it was like
93 Bishop e7
yeah pretty normal moves sure I thought
this was like the Armenian spirit coming
home here with bishop basics yeah that
leg to me well your next couple moves
were very precise I assume it was like
right around here you actually had to
start thinking no no this is important
because I take on eight takes I have to
play b3 be good right like if I play 93
for example you have 24 wins already
yeah because he wants to play Bishop b7
and also C for his hands so there is no
way to defend against that right and one
interesting thing you know we look at
this position part of this compensation
has to be that you owe him a move with
your knight anyone yeah
but now even though you just came from
f3 now you want to go back yeah so now
you want to go back because of the
light-square bishop so i thought this
was all really precise here yeah I
remember I remember queen d1 that's the
last move I remember well that's very
impressive preparation with Queenie so
wait when you say were you prep this
like because you had seen him play this
variation before yeah yeah I said he has
um three games here no no no and there
are actually three games into position
so it's basically and yeah so I to be
honest I was a bit surprised that he I
thought maybe he would try something
else but right I guess he was confident
here I thought white black had a wide
range of moves like maybe Queenie four
might have been more testing or 94 but
Queenie four especially felt like them I
don't know just the move I might do a
Queen d5 of course looks natural but you
know after you just well the other thing
about it was after Queen d5 I was like
you know what this is easier for white
to play yeah it's very surprising that
yeah it looks like a nice attack but
White's moves are just very simple just
yeah
and I guess what I mean by that is he
has to prove something now and you just
have to really just react properly right
he's the one who needs some big idea and
that's why he was really cranking down
on the clock here
so did you guys talk and did he feel
like he maybe should have done something
else right around here I know we didn't
we didn't get a chance to discuss but
like as you said if you go Queenie for I
think rooks you went I'm also not sure
what what he's gonna do right it's this
big quandary where you like the the the
compensation is just abstract right it's
kind of unclear what you want that's
what I thought vision basics was the
move of the day for me I was like what
was that necessary I mean I think I
think he missed b3 because if I don't
have b3 black might be black might just
be better right and and I guess the
intuition would have been for black is
if you're moving back like this then it
can be so bad for me yeah so yeah very
those two moves very precise and here
you're just knocking him out
he must have here been saying to himself
now I'm just gonna settle down to try to
play for a draw surely I mean stay solid
and reasonably saw it and one thing I
was telling everybody earlier that I
really admired here was with f6 and then
he v he's playing to make at least night
life hard for your night on d2 but what
I really liked about what you did here
was right away one sec okay yeah it was
a very interesting moment so I mean here
yeah Queen d3 it took me a while because
at first I thought he could take on f2 I
mean who knew three takes let's take a
look yeah we knew three takes takes
takes takes and it's very important that
after if I live Queen d5 otherwise it's
a very nice trick yeah a very nice trick
so let's just show that and the point is
that the rook here is defended by the
bishop yeah well that's why you know
you're 2600 and I'm not that's nice okay
yeah Knight f8 and then I really like
this because you're just fixing your
knife yeah just wanted a trade and again
right give fix my eye and he says no
already here big time pressure and I
want to highlight another one of the
moves he made that I liked where here
pretty natural rook FD well yeah here
maybe I yeah rook d1 I was I was
concerned about a four actually because
originally I wanted a four rook d7 that
was my concept uh-huh but I don't think
it works cuz he plays a B okay I take on
b7
now the move I miss was Knight d4 hmm so
yeah he had the double attack and for
example if I play Kingi - he'll take on
a2 and unfortunately I can't stop his
pond like rookie yeah yeah okay 783 yes
oh so yeah I probably would have had to
play Knight d2 and then have to but a4
was current would have been also just
controversial because it's really
opening the position even more yeah
that's what I I mean that's what I
basically like I was gonna go 92 but be
wanting yeah a4 could become week later
on so right right and your knight is now
doing something on d2 right it can go to
e for protecting the c4 point is I felt
like as long as that Knight is doing
something you're winning this game I
mean I'm simplistic that's the way I'd
slide yeah Rick c7 and then I really
like your next move
you know I was happy maybe the computer
would say something else but what I
liked about this is you're just
sacrificing a pawn to solve your only
problem right in the position so I
admire that a lot and I think now okay
go ahead very important is okay 94 takes
takes when say takes okay sorry I
thought this is what he would try like
takes takes FGH
95 rook d6 and tried to defend like
Knight a 4 but I think um see if I was
very good here just break it all up so
let's say pawn takes yeah takes and now
I wanted to go rook c4 first include
it's 492 would see to
okay nice yes to go back I saw the
Knights totally yeah I didn't know I
thought just rotate six yeah yeah it's
gotta be lost
yeah the usually two works two nights
with passports was no problem and his
night yeah as nights on and really gonna
be dominated ok another nice variation
and here he was down yeah this is now
there was just hope as I mean very
simple and I was saying you know even if
you didn't have the seat bun you're
still winning this yes yeah I would just
play this through black could resigned
any point by assume he is just kind of
waiting to get a little bit past move
forty so congratulations a beautiful
start to the tournament thank you yeah
and who do you play next round I'm black
against shamone shamone okay good yeah
you can tell us what you're gonna play
against him probably not
okay well thank you very much for her
coming in thanks alright
and we'll now go for a commercial break
we'll be right back question on Twitter
from dem s I should not have pronounced
that that was a bit of a chap here
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like ba3
is an illegal move here because white
advances for two squares or one but it
still is something we call or castle and
you can do that I get to do it instantly
you can't wait for a move I'd let say
play king in seventh game g2 and I'll
try because y'all play four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
at length during the course of my steak
yeah he told me this is that for g5 this
was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think the farthest I know
Oh Lawrence this is not how it works
certainly would be much much more far
necessity to work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of it my quality
of life has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office of the guy
[Music]
you
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience and welcome back to
the 2018 Winter chess classic we just
had a train of winners come in and now
I'm back so a Bensimon grandmaster
jessie cry here in the studio having a
whole bunch of fun here for the very
first round of the winter chess classic
and we did have a couple of we had a
result coming in in Group B and as
theodoro and Michael Webb ski have drawn
their game it was a three-fold
repetition that was our key matchup in
Group B and you were taking a little bit
by surprise that results yeah I was I
thought I think Mick was totally lost
and he's a tricky guy I've had big Mick
on the ropes before and he's very hard
to actually take down and that's what
happened here as well let's take a look
I assume might miss something so rook
takes e8 happened and then rook a1 which
I don't know about rook a 1 white I
would say here has many good moves at
his disposal the point of rook e8 those
can little bit clever and that is if
rook c7 now then big Mick can play rook
c7 to defend so that part is nice and he
must also have an idea on g4 and maybe
the point was that this rook will get
active in a sneaky way here so I guess
f6
I'm not sure about it but let's take a
look F six takes takes takes
mmm this is hard honestly yeah rook
takes and maybe we're living maybe we're
in the land of the living sure but all
right yeah so Ricki a very nice
defensive move this is where we last
left him and yeah and it's a funny thing
as if even if black now loses a pawn
which is what happens here the - but big
mech is going to say is that the two
bishops are sufficient compensation and
it doesn't really help white that the
pawns are doubled on the Queen side so
definitely an advantage for white here
but chances to draw so I was wrong big
Mick I'm sorry you found rook takes a
eight it was a good move well well
defended and let's just run through this
I don't know if we're gonna get the guys
in but even here it looked tough this is
called active defense if you ever want
to learn how to play chess look at big
Mick and active defense and white
basically said you know what I don't
want to risk it and do anything to allow
rook takes B - even though I'm now up
two points because my bishop and my
knight especially while both of them
they're terrible
whereas blacks bishops are very active
so Theodore's got to be upset by that
and it seems like big Mick is slipped
away countess's even though as a draw
count this as a win for the old guys and
you slip away from a position like this
that's a good thing there you go
I really want to jump over quickly to
group a we've got ray Robson versus
Quesada case he's only up upon his
Quesada but Robson looks to be in
trouble here in this endgame I would say
Robson's lost and the problem is not
simply that he's down a pawn his King is
significantly worse and there's been a
number of GM games dating back a long
ways that show that when you're in the
heavy middle game / late a late middle
game let's call it here or endgame and
your King is more exposed that's a bad
thing so even if black wasn't up apart
we'd still have to say that his position
was
beautiful right so a terrible position
for ropes in which in my mind all goes
back to this move on third move 13 d5
which allowed black to get an unclear
position and as might be expected once
this starts happening now anybody can
win because the bishop won b6 is
reasonable and white ended up just
trading it off no problems for black in
this position when you have the space
advantage you must control your
opponent's pieces or your space
advantage will in fact become a problem
for you there are just more things for
black to attack and so here when we left
it actually was something like yeah this
terrible position with a brook a3 yeah
that's where we left it and black is
already better in this position f4
that's a madman's move honestly maybe
that's but you know you're already in
desperation mode here so f4 and blacks
just playing simple chess there goes the
pawn and again already here we can see
the coming endgame where it's not just a
pawn it's that the white king is worse
right
and yeah simple chess I would say this
has already been lost for a long time
but Robeson's fighting on and here we go
the game position they've reached move
40 they'll probably take a little break
but this is totally lost a good king
aged five on the board king h5 on the
board and a good game for everybody to
look at in preparation for our great
favi Carlsen match is the game Fabi
verse is mommy Diarra from the Olympiad
where we also saw this kind of end game
with a weak King this gang on h5 is
truly weak and I suspect there's more
than one way now for black to win this
but in general right the point is simply
that when you've got the King on the run
even exposed in these kinds of heavy end
games it's probably not going to last
that long
do you think that Quezada is will will
end up trading off rooks or Queens here
or is there way to finish it with
everything still like this on the board
we can guarantee that right now he says
to himself I've got 25 minutes and I'm
gonna think until I find a clear win
it's not gonna be like I think until I
find his small advantage or some little
thing no he's going now to end the game
Quesada just played Queen c6 yeah that's
a very natural move so all kinds of
terrible things being threatened the
biggest one being Queen h6 checkmate
I would say so yeah that's too much
that's too much really a bummer four
ropes and yeah because I really admired
the opening that he played and you know
maybe what the young kids need is people
like big Mick and Benjamin and me to
talk to him and say d5 bat but they
probably say yeah I get it I get it old
man okay but you're saying with your d5
bad stuff right
elsewhere in group a multi-level Miro
multi-linear Oh cut off by a rock on the
7 mm-hmm
is this recoverable for Miro do you
think Jessie probably not and let's just
say this is whether modal F wins this or
not this has been a very beautiful
demonstration of how to get an equal ish
endgame position but one that's rich and
then try to outplay your opponent
unless mode unless mural finds something
amazing I mean it's just totally lost
the king is worse and the pawn on e5 is
gonna run and the white king is dreaming
of coming up so yeah totally yeah this
is lost and let's just remind our
viewers that this all started with this
incredible 93 move which looks
absolutely terrible but this is the new
life of efore players that it's very
hard to get any clear advantage against
a 45 whether it's the berlin the petrov
or the ruie it's just a very equal ish
game these days and what white's players
are doing is looking for original ideas
like this where they feel they
understand the position just a little
bit better and can outplay the other guy
in the meantime Quesada has defeated
grey Robson yeah and great start for the
Cuban player and you know I'm really
interested to see how he does in this
event you know we're looking at home and
Ray Robson is very disappointed you know
he is the top seed in this field right
and I know that players say every day is
a new game and you can't hold on to what
was yesterday but right isn't that just
a little bit difficult to do oh yeah I
mean not only that but like he made a
mistake that even I understand
understood it at first glance he knows
that and he knows I'm saying something
terrible about the move d5 right now no
it's terrible to lose a game and yeah
it's always hard especially when you're
white instead such a it wasn't like you
was winning out of the opening but it
was
very dominant position you could tell
that black was uncomfortable oh it looks
like actually you neski okasada actually
made it him on the board yeah
well that we predicted that we knew mate
was coming let's take your lid and take
a look at the define eight so when we
left it
we had Queen C six you have to defend
Queen d2 but then check to the miserable
King the rook comes up and zap I was
doing the puzzlers with the kids the
other day this is the kind of meet and
twos we're looking at yeah it's a brutal
world well you add another one to the
collection yeah okay so as we're nearing
the end of our broadcast time today we
have three games still remaining in
Group A we only have one left in Group B
and I think at this time I'd like to
tell you about some really interesting
events coming up here on our YouTube
channel and in the st. Louis chess club
family wonder what Bobby thinks of these
I think this is really creepy yet it's
the mustache the mustache you know kind
of like the flavor on Faby that I don't
think belongs to it you know what I
think you might you know I think I want
one without the mustache let me put it
that way
maybe because I'm a family man I don't
know why there hey I'll be going to
London for the World Championship I
don't think I'll shave the entire time
it might look a little bit like that
yeah speaking of the World Championship
we've got our own coverage coming up
here this month it's today in chess
round by round coverage with the
Superfriends grandmasters Yasir Sara
Juan Maria Ashley and Wilma Grandmaster
Jennifer Shehadeh the tournament starts
are the match starts on November 9th and
the you can see the full schedule online
there will be a game game rest game game
rest basically up until the end we'll be
presenting this tournament at us chess
champs calm be presenting the match in
an abbreviated format where we will go
on the air kinda like this we'll go on
the air a couple hours later and let's
take a look at what happened today and
yeah today in chess and this is such a
big match I mean this is a match that
I've been waiting for in theory for
years I before I knew of acara wanna you
know what
American in the World Championship match
it's gonna be great Jesse I mean how
pumped are you for this I'm very pumped
I think I've always been pumped I've
loved the world basically you know as a
fan I watched the World Cup every four
years and I watched the World Chess
Championship every two years that's all
I got nothing else really interests me
and this one is the closest in recent
memory I really feel like these guys are
very closely matched even if the wise
chess commentators probably still give
the edge to Carlsen no definitely
Carlson has an edge but I mean you've
got feed a number one versus feed a
that's right now in the world that's
gonna be amazing and yeah and they will
go to to a playoff if it's a tie 66 so
that's the current structure of the
world championship they're also going to
be covering as far as today in chess
Kosar gonna be covering the Women's
World Championship yet 64 player
knockout is actually going on right now
it started a few days ago and by the
time we start today in chess I believe
they'll be at around the round of 16 so
we'll see how our Americans for and
crush are doing actually on the during
vid today in chess broadcast now after
today in chess and we're kind of gonna
overlap today in just a little bit then
this tournament overlaps today in chess
we are closing this year out with a bang
guys the 2018 st. Louis Invitational is
all about norms norms you get three
norms you get the title that that norm
is associated with grandmaster norms
International Master norms that's how
you make a grandmaster we've got a GM
norm hopeful field and an iamb norm
hopeful field that event goes down
November 16th to 21st and we will have
commentary right here from good old
studio B so and then after that my
goodness the grand chest tour finals
from London it never ends
the final four the four players who have
qualified from the big grand chest tour
this year they're gonna complete going
to compete in a miniature knockout
consisting of classical rapid and blitz
all rated by the universal rating system
$300,000 prize fund and the winner will
be the winner not only of the London
classic but also will be the way
the grand chest tour we've got Hikaru
Nakamura Levon Aronian MVL and of course
Fabiano Cara Juana very busy season in
that's right Bobby
I mean think about it this kid is so
amazing that he is playing in so many
events right he's playing this and then
he's gonna go on to play another event
it's kind of like remember when Michael
Phelps decided like he's gonna run need
to do all the events at that one
Olympics in Beijing 2008 right that's
what Bobby's doing he's like oh do I
need a rest like the old guys tell me I
need a rest like that's their chest
wisdom no I want to play right as he's
playing all the time yes he's been very
active this year and he's been on fire
the best year of his career and it's one
of the things I've been I'm acknowledged
I was wrong about years ago I was
talking with some other like Yermo and
other GM's and we were all like no young
man if you want to improve you need to
go home and study your games really
earnestly with a pot of coffee oh hey
just going on he's just gonna play the
next event
yeah and it's it's quite admirable yeah
we've been watching him all year going
back to the candidates tournament in
Berlin and of course in st. Louis he was
one of the three ko winners of the
Sinquefield Cup this year a very unique
situation that happened there so do we
have do we have results or standings for
this tournament thus far okay well right
now we do have still the three games
going on in Group A we do know that
Quesada has won his game against Robson
very important victory there and of
course Geoffrey Zhang winning over
Malcolm yet and once that Jong train
starts going down the tracks I mean it's
hard to stop yeah and I actually I'll
say as a chess fan one interesting thing
about this is there will be many more
events before the next Olympia but
basically Geoffrey is setting himself up
to be on the Olympiad team which is a
very hard team to make that's like
taking the NBA NBA all-stars or
something right to get on that team have
a spot on that team is a big deal and
he's making his campaign now to get on
the team and also you
to say I'm one of the best I can play
with these top four guys and Robson home
man you got a feel for him he's got like
this tiger on his heels here yeah it'll
be really interesting to see how this
one plays that we hope that you join us
for the remaining eight rounds remember
there's no rest day it's easy to
remember set it on a Google Calendar or
something everyday 1 p.m. at US chest
champs calm you can see the games begin
and then we come on the air at 3:30 p.m.
of course the last day is a little bit
different story
we'll get to that a little bit later on
we're gonna have one winner and I in
both fields that's always very exciting
we have encountered playoffs before in
this event but not too many times just
actually only twice so let's wrap it up
what do you say let's wrap it up
tomorrow we'll be right back with you at
3:30 p.m. Central time here at us chest
champs calm where you can watch all the
games live and we hopefully will see
Timur garay of making his st. Louis
return with maybe he'll be wearing like
some groovy zebra pants or something or
a parachute
we're dump it on the plane and we'll see
that video tomorrow too so this this
broadcast was produced by the world's
greatest production B team Tammy Hyde is
the streamer today we have Isaac Krantz
as our graphics and audio man and our
technical director is danny Machuca
so for Grandmaster in-residence Jesse
crying my name is Ben Simon until
tomorrow we say so long from the
show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you